migrant encounters at the border hit a
21-year high last month with agents
detaining more than 200 000 migrants a
419 percent increase over last year
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas was at the border yesterday
calling the situation complicated and
insisting the border is closed but
listen to what he said privately to
border officials in leaked audio fox
news has obtained
it's
exclusively
these numbers cannot continue we cannot
um get to a point where we were a couple
weeks ago
and we're going to make sure that
doesn't happen
we're looking at the policy options we
can't continue like this
our people in the field can't continue
and our system isn't built for it i know
very well
hearing from chief hastings g-forties
and others how close we came to breaking
how close you came to breaking here uh
in this sector
and it's our responsibility to make sure
that
never happens again we don't get that
close again
wow
harris there is a word that we have
heard repeatedly from the biden
administration and that's the word
progress kamala harris said we've made
progress on our southern border
alejandro mayorkas has used that word
gensake has used that word progress
progress progress
this is a very stunning different
verbiage being used in private behind
the scenes we we need transparency on
what their plan looks like and and what
you know progress actually means to them
how they're measuring it if they're
measuring progress by oh we sent
somebody down there and and that person
talked privately at least we thought
that it was mostly private and gave
people kind of an atta boy a pat on the
back and and gave us an idea of what we
need to do next that's one thing um but
if progress
is what it should be and that is solving
the crisis and the problems and turning
off the spigot and putting on a
moratorium um that's a whole different
ball of wax and so we don't know what
they're looking at
which i guess is what allows a president
to say to someone like cuomo you know
basically heck of a job in the middle of
a scandal that caused them to quit a sex
scandal i mean i guess if your idea of
progress is you just went there or
phoned them that's fine but what we need
now with nearly a quarter of a million
people coming across our border in a
month's time
i mean that's ten times the size of most
cities in america most small towns in
america like if if that's what we're
looking for then you're gonna have to
turn off that spicket and look
congressman andy biggs from arizona
there are several now who are banding
together and saying we need to impeach
mayorkas to force him to get the
attention of the administration that
progress looks like doing your job
i let's ask them next white house
briefing what is progress to you
great question i really hope one of the
correspondents asked that morgan we also
heard my orcis and this leaked audio say
it's important never to understate the
situation but then in that same leaked
audio he calls the situation
unsustainable we almost lost a sector
we're going to lose there's a sector on
the point of breaking uh he's
understating it very clearly publicly
saying something different privately
you know kaylee i thought that uh leaked
audio was fascinating because i heard a
dhs secretary who clearly is very
frustrated that he can't do his job
right it was someone behind the scenes i
think i agreed with a lot of what he was
saying he was saying that a legal border
crossing should be illegal that he knew
this was a problem that they needed to
keep title 42 and what's evident from me
the difference in that leaked audio
versus what he is saying publicly it's
evident to me that he's not being
allowed to do his job that he's not
being allowed to put the policies in
place that he knows would stop the flow
of the border so the question is why and
i think it's because this administration
truly does not care if these migrants
are coming over illegally they just
don't
they don't and dagon morgan has a point
there you know he's saying privately
things that would not be allowed to be
said publicly in the biden
administration uh later in the audio he
went on to praise the heroic efforts of
these border agents saying i'm going to
try to get you hazard pay because
they're dealing with kovid he talked
about increasing the number of agents he
talked about ice taking a bigger role
ice the same ice that the left wants to
abolish so is it just untenable for him
to say these things publicly because of
the aoc wing of the party that has such
a grip on what's going on well i think
you've seen with the biden
administration they would rather
talk
than walk
they would rather try to control
language as
as also fascists like to do rather than
implement policies or leave policies in
place that kept our border secure and
kept
again people drug traffickers and human
traffickers from profiting off of human
misery and suffering whether it's
trafficking drugs or children so
remember earlier in the year jinsaki
over and over wouldn't call it a crisis
she referred to it as a challenge we
could take i guess a sliver of solace in
the fact that secretary mayorkas at
least privately acknowledges what we can
see with our own eyes in terms of the
video that we've shot in terms of what
we're hearing from whether it's mayors
or border patrol agents all up and down
the border or just looking at the
numbers
coming in monthly of the highest number
of apprehensions in more than two
decades
so it again i think the only thing that
could turn it around is the poll numbers
have moved against this administration
so much what only 35 percent approve of
the handling of immigration they care
more about the polls than the human
suffering so maybe this gets them off
their you know what's to actu actually
deal with this crisis that's affecting
so many americans
yeah there's nothing like polling always
motivating politicians to finally act
dan one agent stood up to my orchestra
saying this for those of us who have
been around long enough we don't need to
reinvent the wheel we've seen this
happen before we know exactly how to
shut it down we need to make a legal
entry illegal that sounds like common
sense from someone there on the ground
yeah it's always good to listen to the
guys and the gals on the ground they
usually know the situation best look i
think there's three things that this
administration needs to be doing and we
talked about the first one which is
admit publicly we have a crisis at the
southern border secondly we've got to
throw more resources at this challenge
at this crisis
secretary mayor has talked about
increasing the number of border patrol
agents really our first line of defense
by 2000 in 2023 i think that this crisis
demands more immediate action more
technology and more people and then
third we haven't had comprehensive
immigration reform since 1986
so both parties need to come together
with some bipartisan consensus on
concrete measures to make the southern
border safe